max gros louis a lutté toute sa vie
contre les préjugés à l'endroit des
premières nations aux biens poids de
l'histoire du canada que les canadiens
français ont appris les saveurs puis ça
va amener petit bébé puis savage qui
étaient des barbares puis tous ces
choses là il ya encore des gens qui
pensent comme ça
né le 6 août 1931 dans la réserve de
wendake et à québec
il montre rapidement son caractère à
l'école n'acceptant aucune insulte sur
ses origines autochtones à l'école je
suis devenu champion boxeur parce que
monsieur fait que d'être savage autant
parler vrai qu'à part les soeurs peut
parler les enfants mais 15 des français
craignent qu'avec moi jeune adulte il
sera tour à tour guide de chasse et
pêche vendeur est responsable d'une
troupe de danse en 1964 alors
propriétaire de magasin d'artisanat
il était le grand chef de la nation
huronne wendat frondeur et bon orateur
il devient un porte parole influents
auprès des gouvernements en dénonçant
notamment l'occupation du territoire par
hydro québec
vous savez que vous êtes une minorité au
canada mais je voulais faire écouter
vous devriez en tout premier lieu
respecter une minorité qui permet vous à
québec
max gros-louis ira jusqu'à réclamer 85 %
de la superficie de la ville au nom de
la nation huronne wendat
bien entendu on veut pas que les gens
partent à vis de leur maison une brute
alors je pense qu'on demande
on veut s'asseoir ensemble on venus de
si affable parfois critiqué pour ses
liens étroits avec les politiciens il
réussi à étendre le territoire de wend à
quai à cinq reprises
l'essor économique de la réserve de
wendake qui se poursuivra dans les
années 2000 avec la construction de
musées hôtels et l'arrivée de commerces
en 2008 dans la foulée des célébrations
du 400e de québec
il est défait par konrad sioui après
plus de 30 ans à la tête de la nation
huronne wendat au nom du président de la
république française vous vous remettons
les insignes d'officier de la légion de
la retirer de la vie politique
max gros louis et décoré de la légion
d'honneur de france est nommé officier
de l'ordre national du québec et du
canada
son rêve de voir la loi fédérale sur les
indiens m
dit fier afin de reconnaître la pleine
autonomie des premières nations
demeurent inachevés à ce jour ici
olivier lemieux radio canada québec
[Musique]